fun
[Musique]
deux mille ans d'existence un
demi-millénaire de tradition d'éclat le
prestige mondial
une ville qui fut et qui est encore une
sorte de capitale universelle la ville
lumière la ville reine paris 1960 sonne
parier sa région plus de huit millions
d'habitants
paris la plus grande ville française
une ville qui de plus en plus ressembler
new york à londres aux grandes cités
modernes de l'acier du verre et du béton
paris connaît aujourd'hui tous les
problèmes des villes géantes le bruit la
trépidation l'air vicié la circulation
impossible
les logements trop rares on ne vit pas à
paris en cours
on se précipite et pourtant en dépit de
toutes les difficultés matérielles la
région parisienne reçoit chaque année
cent mille personnes de plus que
viennent chercher les nouveaux venus à
paris des emplois des salaires plus
élevés
c'est peut-être une autre vie une vie
différente de la vie qu'ils ont connue
en province car à la fin du xxème siècle
paris reste la ville où l'on arrive à
les paris de tous les prestiges de la
réussite
et puis en province on pense quelques
fois que paris est la ville où l'on
s'amuse demandons aux parisiens aux
anciens et aux nouveaux ce qu'ils
pensent de leur vie
[Musique]
vous savez le taxi dans paris on perd
beaucoup de choses on perd la vie réelle
on n'a plus d'appétit en france vers la
paix le tir
on dort plus beaucoup quelquefois il y
en a qui sont agités dorment plus
j'en déduis qs descente qu'il faut pas
répéter parce que quand je suis content
aussi j -marie vous sur le faire de la
banlieue ou de choses dans ce genre là
et bien je
mange davantage le midi que les autres
jours que quand je roule dans paris
mettons les nerfs en prennent un bon
coup
mais je ne suis pas à l'abri même moi
quand je rentre le soir toute la journée
ça va bien où on est pris dans
l'encombrement pas dans l'ambiance on la
droite à gauche aussi de suite
et quand la voiture est rentrée dans le
box et bien un coup de barre me prends à
ce moment-là et javon quelquefois c'est
pourtant pour loin bauxite à mon box
était à 3 400 mètres de chez moi
eh bien j'ai eu du mal au rejet du mal
géré comme un bon père je veux lille à
la sava plus un ça coince la renault
charente
[Applaudissements]
longtemps que vous êtes libre moi ça
fait depuis 1914 1914 et vous êtes
contents de ce métier moi je peux pas
faire autre chose vous vous demandez
combien vous gagnez continentaux ou par
semaine oh ben ça fait à peu près dans
les vingt mille la mise par semaine tous
les jours comment ça ce matin à 5h30
cet or quoi puis alors je finis soir à 6
heures la circulation c'est très dur de
vivre à paris selon ce moment c'est un
peu chic l'albien approché pacheco de
mondragon ne peut pas se mettre dans les
rues on ne peut pas s'arrêter est
toujours des voitures qui sont leur
stationnement et alors il faut faire
vite et comme j'ai 65 ans alors et ça
commence à être un peu dur quoi
soyons tous voulu vous étiez voir enfin
quatre ans j'y suis et ce que je faisais
avant a toujours été libre un témoin ça
vous plaît comme youtube pour bien c'est
dur
certes on peut avancer ça les problèmes
de la circulation
j'aime beaucoup les professionnels mais
il s'allonge aussi considérablement les
trajets des travailleurs il est courant
de voir des durées de trajet est de 1h
1h30 et même une heure trois quarts pour
des travailleurs de la région parisienne
et salaires sont ils en rapport avec cet
allongement inévitable de la durée du
travail
mademoiselle êtes-vous parisienne cinq
ans vous apprenez donc en province we
had dans le mot clé oui je sais rien
mais à paris non je suis à rennes
pour l'instant parisienne bien sûr
m'enfin je suis né en provence
c'est un viol non sire je veux toujours
vécu
enfin arrivé j'habite dans cet
arrondissement j'avais dans le xiiie
j'habite à la varenne en banlieue
j'habite dans la banlieue j'habite
onéguine temps pour venir ici
une heure et demie de métro et de bus
une heure là car une heure et demie
heure je me paie bien à paris sorti un
peu trop de bruit quand même maintenant
pas que je sois dessus mais un petit peu
quand même
qu'est ce que vous appelez la vie
parisienne des très difficile c'est à
dire je peux toujours courir c'est ce
que je fais tout le temps d'ailleurs
oui enfin c'est beaucoup moins agréable
que la vie de province galloise point de
vue
travaillons pour lui c'est beaucoup vous
mentez m'enfin malgré un fromage est-ce
que vous accepteriez de partir avant
oui n'importe qui n'importe où louis
saha sont proposées ce qu'on gagne les
avantages que j'ai ici je repartirai je
n'ai encore jamais envisagé partir en
province et non pas pour le moment oui
malgré tout et j'estime que la vie est
quand même
enfin c'est calme peut faire rester
appareils ou bien l'autre 50 10 c'est à
dire comme je suis pas mis lyon valence
avignon aussi comme moi combien vous
gagnez en traitement oui 600 à 650
points
14 à 1000 par mois soixante dix mille
francs par mois ici 70 ça est ce que
vous faites des économies
non je ne peux pas vous pouvez pas parce
que vous ne manquent pas mais n'arrivait
pas à dépenser beaucoup à paris vous
trouvez qu'on dépense beaucoup appareils
oui énormément
par rapport à la vie en province et
beaucoup plus onéreux
on a plus de chance de pouvoir faire des
économies en province qu ici
[Musique]
il ya des havres de paix à paris et tout
le monde n'habite pas la banlieue
souvent les parisiens ne sortent
pratiquement jamais de leur quartier et
paris est alors un agglomérat de villes
de province et même de village les
sociologues ont étudié de près
l'itinéraire dans paris des demoiselles
du 16e alors que souvent ce quartier
j'en sors pour mon travail
oui beaucoup sinon pour mes loisirs je
reste souvent dans le quartier de
beaulieu
oui je travaillais sur tech et je
travaille pour des expositions des
congrès des salons c'est très
intéressant que le niveau loisir voulez
vous les prenez surtout dans ce quartier
c'est à dire vous avez vous rencontré
avec des allures oui j'ai énormément
dhabi d'un mille qui habite le quartier
les genêts voit très souvent ou sortait
souvent le 16e arrondissement
oui pour la les airs en à l'efap voit ce
que ça se trouve rue de rennes
c'est à dire à côté des deux magots
enfin telle église
saint-germain-des-prés
vous aimeriez du terrain d'autres
quartiers de paris oui pourquoi pas
google peut-être sur les quais de presse
des de lille le salon les salles oui
certainement il ya beaucoup de quartiers
qui me tenterait particulièrement l'île
saint louis
nous sommes le oui vous connaissez ici
par exemple baisse non pas du tout pour
le tout pas du tout pour y être passé de
3 fois peut-être mais enfin connaître
non à dire que je connais vos amis vous
les rencontrez dans ses démons vont
doucement
en général oui la plupart du temps vous
rencontrez dans les soirées
oui dans l'histoire même plus tellement
maintenant surtout des petits dîners ou
du petit cocktail même des verts qu'on
va prendre les uns chez les autres
en général quand je vais à une soirée je
suis avec énormément d'amis et on décide
quelquefois de finir la soirée chez
castel dans ce cas là j'y vais mais je
ne décide pas un soir tient ce soir j'ai
envie d'aller chez castel je n'aime pas
du tout les boîtes et
j m j'y vais jamais que vous évoquez
93,20 évoque pour vous la province et
quelques endroits où je ne vous pas du
tout habité je n'ai jamais habité alors
je ne peux pas exactement ce que ça
représente
[Musique]
que s'est passé beaucoup moins savamment
- vivants - distraction peut paris
j'aime beaucoup la campagne je pourrais
faire du sport beaucoup de cheval du
tennis j'aurai plus de temps pour vivre
aussi certainement à paris on est
toujours pressé vous aimait beaucoup la
campagne si vous aviez toute l'année
parce que sur des temps j'entends
j'aurais envie de revenir à paris
j'aurais un peu la nostalgie de paris
parce que après tout les pavés de paris
je les aime bien
j'ai des amis ou des parents même qui
ont habité la province et qui pour eux
on garde un souvenir
quelquefois comptable et puis si je vais
en province et parce que je serais
mariée parce que sinon je vois pas
pourquoi j'irais en province alors
j'aime beaucoup l'homme parce que je
vais retransformer comme sun si je doit
habiter la province parce que mon mari
travaille là bas je l'habille très très
volontiers
ça ne me déplairait absolument pas
paris au travail paris ouvriers depuis
plus de 100 ans comment vivent les
ouvriers à paris
sont ils atteints par les névroses qui
s'ajoute à celle d'un travail harassant
paris reste encore très largement la
ville des usines et du travail
industriel
la durée du trajet est longue de la
maison l usine et journée à la chaîne
sont durs surtout pour les jeunes
provinciaux qui n'ont pas l'habitude
alors où trouver l'évasion paris cette
ville qui attire toujours les français
est elle pas d'abord la ville dont tous
les parisiens cherchaient à sortir
[Musique]
vous pensé vivre en province sauvette
appliquant certainement pourquoi on aura
d'abord le repos puis à ce moment là je
crois qu'on serait j'aurais plus d'une
trentaine d'années je serais déjà placé
dans la vie j'aurai plus besoin à tout
le monde de sortir le soir je passerai
mon confort bon le retrait 33 sur l'a6
puis je crois c'est votre avis daniel
oui m'enfin pour plus tard tout même
tout d'abord j'y pense pas beaucoup
maintenant un point que je connais pas
beaucoup de chance mais enfin j'espère
on traite même mois plus tard un confort
matériel hors de paris paris et pierre
au plus tard jouer à gauche moi je n'ai
pas d'idée savoir si j'habite près de
paris où la période plus tard d'ailleurs
si ça peut changer la situation et à
l'est par rapport à la province parce
que ça se rappelle le besoin plus avec
la décentralisation bonne chose qui
change
[Musique]
paris à ces dieux qui ne sont pas
éternels les couturiers les producteurs
de cinéma
les grands acteurs les chanteurs et
aussi les coiffeurs vrai le 70 les
grands coiffeurs
ils viennent souvent nous province année
- contre grecque
le cours commence et nous si nous
faisions ont prévu des chouettes tout
petit peu plus long eq c'est la grande
mode de coiffure de printemps est dictée
secours égèrement bouclé je dois je dois
tellement à paris surtout parisienne
mais je reste très amoureux la province
alors parlé un petit peu de paris si
vous voulez bien cette vie dit
trépidante
est-ce que vous la ressentez pas oh oui
bien sûr parce que je commence très tôt
le matin je suis le chaque jour le
premier arrivé à mon salon et bien
souvent le dernier en partir surtout que
le métier que je que je fais m'oblige en
plus ce sont plus d'une longue journée
de travail d'affaires à participer dans
les studios de cinéma les studios de
photos a travaillé quelques fois très
tard le soir par exemple en période de
connexion depuis bientôt deux mois déjà
mais jeune collaboratrice et moi même
nous avons passé une partie de nos nuits
dans les studios et les photos est ce
que cette vie parisienne et épuisante
pour vous
oui mais vous avez aussi fait très bien
c'est très agréable je fais un métier
qui me plaît énormément tout à fait un
merveilleux pour un homme
le contact des jolies femmes toute
l'année surtout de diriger toute cette
équipe de jeune collaboratrice qui sont
jolis qui sont charmants qui aiment leur
métier
c'est très très agréable ici il vous
toutes les jeunes nous la faisons dates
sont presque tous des jeunes filles du
midi de toulon de saint tropez de
marseille
elles ont un succès fou d'abord je crois
que le côté leur accent leur donne un
charme particulier qui le rappelle les
vacances et le montant même les jolies
filles à paris ne manquent pas
d'activités
j'habitais paris depuis toujours qu'est
ce que vous faites de beaux
qu'est ce que vous faites à paris dans
la mode en tant que mannequin
monica je fais des photos j'ai fait deux
beaux fils excellent
j'habite paris beaucoup mieux maintenant
pourquoi parce qu'on a besoin quand même
de faire les choses avec s'est séparé
sans toujours avoir une petite chose
votre métier votre vie c'est la mode
parce que vous croyez que vous auriez
peut réussir ailleurs capable au début
n'ont certainement pas pourquoi on n'a
plus de contacts sur paraissait moins
fermé comme actuellement
eh bien je ne fus peu des stylistes de
la mode des achats avant des modèles en
effet toute l'équipe
regardons crédit les demoiselles des
grandes administrations ont parfois des
métiers parallèle
[Musique]
tu es plus de pincettes quel âge
avez-vous 20 ans qu'est ce que vous
faites je travaille je garde le site
hier
dès menton jean jacques dessalines était
une fête que ça non bien sûr
je travaille également dans la semaine
dans une bonne administration et
l'américaine je les passe si à
travailler ce qui vous permet d'agrandir
mon podium ça vous amuse de travail en
mai beaucoup et où alors vous ne pensez
pas 6 quelquefois le soir le samedi soir
et le dimanche après midi
je passe ma journée ici qu'est ce que
vous faites de votre argent
à de mon argent qu'est-ce que peut en
faire une fille savait paris quand même
très alléchant les vitrines vous attire
beaucoup d' on ira entrée en ressort
avec une robe une jupe ou des
chaussettes
voyons les grands journalistes comme
henri de turenne
aujourd'hui on peut faire de la
journaliste me dans différents domaines
on peut faire du journalisme écrit que
vous le savez on va faire du journalisme
me parler on peut faire du journalisme
télévisé c'est la vraie raison alors la
raison pour laquelle moi je vais seuils
de comment dirais-je d'exercer mon
métier dans ces différents domaines
c'est par intérêt professionnel ce n'est
pas par intérêt les mic en matériel
industriel par exemple à certaines
machines à sa disposition
et puis un beau matin on invente une
nouvelle machine au moins je suis
journaliste je ne sers d'une note de ma
plume puis de la machine à écrire et
puis voilà tout d'un coup qu'on nous dit
mme avec une caméra aussi on peut
raconter des histoires alors je vais pas
me priver de ce plaisir vous comprenez
ça m'intéresse et puis j'essaie de m'en
servir plus ou moins bien enfin j'essaye
alors encore une question
aimez-vous paris puisque vous habitez
paris comment savoir si on aime paris on
n'a pas le temps de en profiter oui oui
quand même
on aime paris on aime paris à cause de
toutes les possibilités qu'on trouve ici
comme on dirait c'est un monde tellement
immense que à paris on peut jamais
s'ennuyer ressemble une question d'être
un peu dur désigné vous la province pour
autant a sûrement pas je ne dédaigne pas
la province mais je m'étais jamais posé
la question on a toujours envie d'aller
en province d'abord je dois si vous avez
remarqué mais plus les villes
grandissent plus les gens ont soif
d'aller se promener à la campagne il
n'ya d'édition qu'à paris thérèse de
saint phalle directrice littéraire d'une
des plus grosses maisons parisiennes et
romancière à succès nous parle de sa vie
professionnelle
est ce que vous croyez qu en tant qu
auteur de romans c'est à paris qu'on
peut le mieux écrire il y a deux raisons
la première c'est que paris est
stimulant pour l'esprit
c'est un lieu de rencontre après ces
rencontres après ces événements qui vous
ont bouleversé brusquement trois mois
six mois après tout d'un coup après
avoir engrangé vous éprouvez le besoin
de restituer sa et vous le faites sous
forme de roman est là il faut le silence
mais pour engranger comme vous dites
l'avis de paris est nécessaire à ce que
vous avez découvert des personnages de
vol de lourdement à paris gilles savez
on écrit avec ses tripes plutôt qu'avec
ton cerveau on écrit avec son
inconscient donc c'est très difficile de
savoir si les personnages viennent de de
paris ou non les décors oui bien sûr
parce que il y a les quais de la seine
ya les boîtes des bouquinistes il ya
tout ce côté poétique et merveilleux de
l'île de la cité de l'île saint louis
etc
paris oui paris à la fois est un choc
par toutes les rencontres qu'on y fait
un stimulant pour l'esprit et paris
aussi est un élément politique
merveilleuse suffit d'aller se promener
autour de notre dame voir les cerisiers
en fleurs pour être bouleversée ou bien
aux tuileries navan martre namor tous
vous promener dans paris et los gelé
beaucoup fait et oui quand on reste à
paris le samedi le dimanche on le fait
que dans les bouquets dans un bureau
bien sûr que non mais
paris je crois que c'est tout de même
lieu et au monde ouvrier revenu vivre
paris ville lumière
on le disait dans 19 centres aujourd'hui
paris c'est miss un peu à l'heure de new
york avec ces drug stores ces avenues au
néon ces gadgets ville traditionnelle de
la détente et du plaisir
paris offrant vrac toutes les névroses
de la fin du xxème siècle à côté des
distractions traditionnels comme le
théâtre fréquenté beaucoup par la
province où l'étranger il y a les clubs
les mini salons de danse les magasins à
disque et puis le paris nocturne le
parisen aube
celui des nouveaux princes ruche de la
caf est ce ça et et qui ne sont plus des
oisifs mai des danseurs des peintres des
écrivains la nuit aussi paris se
distraient dans ces cellules fermées où
se rejoignent les copains de tous âges
et de tous milieux
[Musique]
vous avez encore un magasin ya un tas de
choses chez votre était curieuse et
parisiens achètent beaucoup j'avais
beaucoup de provinciaux aussi qui
viennent dans les reconnaissances l'état
s'est ouvert à partir de quelle heure si
ça ferme à quelle heure deux heures
d'histoire et de pratiquer le même
métier en province
et puis comme c'est beaucoup plus calme
il y aura certainement pas des gens
jusqu'à 2 heures du matin les tout
jeunes sont encore attiré par les
distractions traditionnel des foires
[Musique]
vous êtes à paris
vous amuser beaucoup non qu'est-ce que
vous avez commandé une action mont rose
pâle
et l'endroit à la marie je vous fais
dans la vie
j'apprends métier
notre ancien d'envoi d'un 15e ceci en
électronique
[Musique]
c'est la névrose des mécaniques pour les
jeunes le 220 chrono à paris n'a pas
beaucoup de sens
on n'a rien à faire en 1940 monteur en
fait on fait un bond de 120 chrono
220 pour nous et l'on pratique souvent
dans paris le 220 heures dans paris non
c'est un petit peu difficile
en fait avec les limitations de vitesse
dans paris on n'est pas supposé dépasser
les 60
qu'est-ce que vous éprouvez d'avoir une
voiture aussi puissante et aussi rapide
dans paris dans paris on a un petit peu
on est obligé de se freiner un peu parce
qu'on a toujours tendance à passer les
vitesses limitées mais
on attend le grand plaisir c'est quitter
paris et pouvoir s'en aller sur la route
ou accélérer sentir la puissance
enfin les gens qui aiment conduire est
ce que vous pensez comme provincial peut
profiter davantage une voiture vous
allez certainement pourquoi parce que
les routes sont puis dégager les routes
sont plus dégagées
il n'a pas tellement a pas tellement de
trajet de ville à faire en fait il se
trouve toujours sur des grandes routes
là on peut rouler vite on peut servir de
la puissance dans l'enfer mécanique de
paris ou sur l'iso a dit ce qu'on m'a
fait beaucoup de kilomètres comme ça km
2 km
tous les jours on fait un nom j'essaie
de venir une fois par semaine ça fait
longtemps je voulais l'issue bien non
parce que le centre où s'est ouvert que
depuis quelques jours nous allons
première fois que c'est exact pourquoi
venez-vous c'est bien parce que j'ai un
emploi essentiellement sédentaires je
travaille dans un bureau et même quand
je me déplace à paris je le prends le
métro bien la voiture
ici justement pour compenser un petit
peu mon travail intellectuel pensez-vous
les armes en arrière l'outil est soit
20,6
monsieur je m'excuse de vous interrompre
combien de fois c'est tout cet exercice
15 grâce fois on est souvent ici c'est
la sixième fois la sixième fois
pourquoi venez-vous juillet soit au ban
du physique puisse amène une détente une
certaine détente je suis garde détente
quelle profession car se fit dans le
bâtiment et besoins devaient tendre
c'est parce qu'ils ont encore fait
d'effort physique aussi parce que
j'arrive à un âge où je commence à voir
des vents plus ça je veux m'entretenir
dit peu nous avons des gens qui viennent
rechercher une bonne condition physique
se remettre en retrouver une bonne santé
et aussi se détendre se délasser les
gens travaillent dans un bureau font
beaucoup de voitures ont une
alimentation trop riche et surtout ne
font aucun exercice physique
on en met en attente et le samedi soir
les boulevards les champs elysées sont
envahies d'une marée mécanique qui
tourne interminablement à la recherche
d'une place de préférence hors des
parkings
que cherchent ces parisiens du samedi
venu de la lointaine banlieue les
trottoirs la lumière aussi le cinéma au
fauteuil de luxe aux affiches
alléchantes
alors cela mérite bien une demi heure de
queue même dans le froid
c'est là par hasard ou alors vous allez
l'avoir genre de film j'ai choisi de
vous avez choisi le prix joan obtenu
pour une raison personnelle pour les
acteurs il a descendu voir ainsi des
mains puis toutes les semaines
toutes les semaines mais très cinéphile
assidus à peu près oui sur le plan cible
sur le plan acteur metteur en scène dans
ses urines tout
[Musique]
paris à l'heure anglaise mais les clubs
parisiens limites que de très loin les
bottes nom de jane ils ont un côté
france est bonne en cent mille quintaux
en groupe on s'y retrouve
non pas entre hommes mais entravé je
vais vous avez un habitué de ces
établissements mais si je suis patron
rapport excusez moi bien et puisque vous
êtes le patron dit mais qu'est ce que
c'est aussi un club privé
bah c'est un club qui est réservé aux
journalistes à bord quant aux gens de la
presse de la radio du cinéma
alors on a cherché alors créer un
endroit confortable au sens qu'ici vous
avez un les vignes avec des fauteuils
des petites tables basses en acajou
alors on a des reporters qui viennent du
monde entier des journalistes qui
viennent par exemple d'amérique à 4
heures du matin qui peut venir manger
quelque chose dans ces éventuellement et
prendre un bain s'ils le veulent puisque
la discothèque est équipé d'une salle de
bain moi j'ai remarqué que quand on
arrive devant votre porte
je n'ai pas fait ce qu'elle part de
prison mais enfin il ya une sorte de
deux mots de passe il faut une clé il
faut tous cas vous avez d'abord une
plaque une petite médaille que l'on
donne à tous les membres du club ont
carrément 700 qui sont enseignées sur un
registre un cahier
ces gens là veulent rentrer en principe
sans histoire mais pour faciliter
l'entrée de très bons clients
nous avons entre les gens qui l'ont
leurs clés mettre la balle en touche sur
des voitures rentrent tranquillement son
histoire là dans des domaines comme chez
soi
les jeunes sont sectaires ils ont leur
club particulier avec leurs disques
leurs danses leurs névroses et aussi
leur rêve celui style bernard cazals et
vous non
qu'est-ce que vous fait la vie
d'étudiant fondait vous venez souvent
ici tous les dimanches qu'est ce que
vous faites quand vous ne venez pas ici
[Applaudissements]
vous vous amusez ici moyennement
alors pourquoi venez vous pour retrouver
mais voilà qu'est ce que vous avez
comment autres distractions
cinéma
[Musique]
choupo alors est ce matin et le théâtre
c'est peut être très intéressant mais je
n'ai même pas parfait est ce que vous
êtes parisien je n'ai toujours habité
par y trouver toujours ici vous
n'habitez pas paris où aimeriez vous
vivre très loin de la france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et les locomotives
on appelle ainsi les gens qui lancent la
mode qui attire le tout-paris dans les
endroits obscurs secret mystérieux et
fascinant comme les papillons dit
annabelle régime patachou jacques chazot
évoque ce pari des nouvelles sociétés
secrètes paris où les mêmes se retrouve
chez des tiers à new york et demain à
deauville ou à tahiti ou à saint tropez
[Musique]
pêche où vous habitez paris depuis
toujours depuis toujours oui je suis
parisien est né à paris de parents nés à
paris vous aimez paris je n'aime que
paris en fait j'aime bien j'aime bien
tout le reste j'ai beaucoup voyagé comme
peut-être vous le savez mais je n'aime
complètement que paris oui je croyais
très malheureux si je devais si je
devais savoir que je que je dois vivre
ailleurs et ne plus jamais revenir à
paris paris pour cela plus une histoire
d'amour jeu tendre que je déteste dont
je ne veux pas me passer
en fait je suis pas du tout provincial
en tous les cas pas monteur je crois que
je dois être quatrième génération le
parisien c'est assez formidable et j'ai
jamais aimé tellement vivre à paris
complètement ne peut pas rester très
longtemps sans venir non plus je crois
que je me ferais est complètement
impossible
un exemple précis j'arrive des états
unis où devait rester deux ans elle
n'est pas eu le courage m'a fallu
rentrer je repartirai à 68 mais deux en
amérique
impossible aujourd'hui par ailleurs
quand je suis à l'étranger mais je ne
m'ennuie pas parce que je sais que je
peux revenir quand je veux ce serait
dramatique serait franchie si je pensais
que je dois jamais
moi je sais que dès que je suis trois
jours loin de paris du malade
bottemanne à quoi ça tient cesser les
pierres c'est la lumière ça tu sais les
gens les rues de paris c'est tout ce qui
me plaît et je m'explique pas à paris on
peut se promener seul on peut imaginer
rêver se souvenir enfin on peut se
promener aussi à new york
alors pour rêver à new york il faut se
lever tôt non j'aime déambuler dans la
rue nous j'aime faire des bisous vitrine
enfin si je très pressé brusquement si
je me mets marché pour ça que j'ai vite
le plus possible de trouver le premier
taxi parce que dès que je commence je
peux aller comme ça pendant des
kilomètres regarder les vitrines ça
m'évite symbole et je crois que la vie
parisienne est une des choses les plus
angoissantes
mais je crois de la ville en jeu la vie
en général dans les grandes villes et ça
je crois qu'en province
on se dit mon dieu à paris se passe des
choses comme j'aimerais y être comme les
gens ont une vie agréable je crois que
c'est pas vrai je crois que si on a la
chance de vivre à la campagne des petits
quoi peut-être par moments on s'ennuie
un petit peu fait possible on a le temps
de penser est justement là le temps de
regarder ce que les parisiens n'ont pas
le temps de faire ils sont angoissés ils
ont leur travail dans un pot il coup ils
ont pas taxi pas d'autobus
on court après le métro laurier c'est
pour ça je pensais pas du tout seul dans
l'art ils ont pas le temps de retrouver
quelqu'un ils courent après leur vie a
gagné et leur travail d'affaires qui est
beaucoup plus dures et les parisiens et
paris a toujours la même force et la
même magique à l'étranger
[Musique]